- I'm a big fan of the WNBA.
- You think about the NBA, in its 25th year, was not
where it is now in year 75.
- Right.
- And so it's so much opportunity and so much growth
that's coming.
But what I really love about the W is the activism.
I just love the way that the W stands together.
- Mmhmm.
- You know? Locked arms.
It's not one person. It's the whole league.
And every time something social,
something that hits home,
something that's important to talk about,
that we need voices, it's the W who steps up first.
- Yeah, that's one of the things I love most about it
is like, I feel like everyone in there is so empowered
to just, like, say whatever they think.
And I think it's like the demographic that we have too.
It's like predominantly, like, gay Black women in the league.
- Mmhmm.
- And so that's like a minority.
And so we feel like now we have the platform
where we can talk about these things,
and then we see other things,
like other injustices happening.
And, you know, maybe we knew how that felt,
so we wanna speak out against that.
Or, I just feel like they're so fearless.
And, like, as a group, we're so powerful—
- Facts.
- That we know, like, the platform that we have now.
And so whenever we see something that we don't think
is right, we feel like not only should we do it,
but it's kind of, like, on our shoulders to be able to speak out.
- I think one of the things about the WNBA
and their social activism,
it was never a one-and-done for them.
They've been doing it for well over a decade,
probably for the full 25 years.
I'm Cathy Engelbert, the commissioner of the WNBA.
I think the events of 2020, where we had the entire league
in one place in the WNBA bubble in Florida at IMG Academy,
and I think what happened then is now millions know that
the WNBA players have such strong social justice stances.
And I think it's really important that people know
what they stand for.
And they've been such leaders in this area.
- As the NBA, we look to the W first—
- Mmhmm.
- And see what they're doing more times than not.
They speak on, you know, things that are going on in the world
before we do.
You know what I'm saying?
I think we kinda follow their lead to a point.
So, I think that's the best part about the W is how
they're so ahead of everything.
And just to support that—you know,
obviously they give us, and we give back.
- I feel like it can even get better.
Like, the relationship between the W and the NBA.
Everybody come together and voice their opinion
about things that's going on in the world.
- I feel like la—um, not last year, 2020. That was like—
- Yeah.
- We kinda wanna stand
in solidarity to you guys when you stepped out of the game.
- Mmhmm, right.
- Like, we want that too.
We wanna be, like, with you guys—
- Right.
- And making sure that
we're standing as, like, a united front.
- For sure.
- Coming off that playoffs—
- Mmhmm.
- It was incredible.
If you love basketball, to be able to watch that
playoffs, the WNBA playoffs, was amazing.
How can you guys assist?
Or how can we all help the popularity continue to grow?
- Us as the NBA, guys going to their games,
showing love and support.
- Mmhmm.
- I see that a lot more.
- We just awarded the inaugural Kobe
and Gigi Bryant WNBA Advocacy Award at the NBA All-Star Game
this year to Chris Paul, who's been a huge advocate.
Not only for youth sports,
but also of the WNBA, their players.
It's those kind of advocates, like Kobe Bryant was
for the women's game, that we need to expand upon.
And I think NBA players have done that.
I've never seen such great support.
There's a reason why the WNBA has been
the only women's professional sport to last 25 years.
And that's double any other women's professional league
in America. Think about that.
It's because we share the NBA brand.
- I just bought my first WNBA jersey the other day.
- [Collier:] Nice.
- So, you know, wear that in the tunnel, you know, as the season gets closer.
I like the, you know, kind of the orange hoodie thing they did
a couple years ago.
I thought that was, like, super cool to kinda build momentum
towards your guys' season.
But I think at the same time, like we were talking
about earlier, you were talking about, like, controversy helps too.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Collier:] Mmhmm.
- Like, the more conversations we have about the league,
like, good or bad—
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, it does help, and it brings attention.
And there's so much great basketball played
that, you know, the more people that actually sit down and watch a game,
they'll fall in love with it.
- You guys just got a $75 million, you know, capital raise.
- [Collier:] Yep.
- Can you tell us about it?
What does that—where do that money go?
How does that help the league grow?
- I mean, I honestly don't know where the money—like,
I don't know how it's distributed.
- The $75 million capital raise was really
a watershed moment for women's professional sports.
And I think once again, the WNBA, we're leading around
how to deploy that capital to grow the game.
Both the youth side of the game,
as well as the professional side of the game
and everything in between.
And so we're gonna make it easier to be a fan.
We're gonna, you know, look at a five-year business transformation
to, you know, change our digital products,
meet our fans where they are.
They're very digital. They want content.
They want year-round content.
We're also looking at globalizing the game.
We're looking at innovation like NFTs and sports betting.
And ESPN just launched the first-ever WNBA fantasy game,
for instance.
So, how do you draw in that fan,
keep that fan,
get them to come to arenas,
get them to watch on our very different platforms?
And we're just continuing looking at optical tracking
and wearables and lots of different innovative things,
which, before raising this capital,
we didn't have the ability to do.
- You have to spend money to make money.
- Right.
- And that's always people's arguments.
Like, if you want people to come, you have to promote revenue.
Like, you have to put in money to something for it to grow.
- Does that make you excited about where the future
of the game is going and, you know, and you can see, like,
"OK, now we have people believing in us a little bit more"?
- Yeah, it's really exciting.
And we have some great partners.
Like, we—they call each other Changemakers.
- Mmhmm.
- Cuz they're, like, trying to make a difference
in women's sports and in our league.
So, it's awesome to see that because, like, you guys
were talking, it was funny about the stylist.
You're like, "Do you care what the price tag is?"
And you're like, "Nah, I got that new contract.
I don't care."
- [Laughing]
- I'm like—I'm still, like, budgeting on my contract.
- So, it's awesome.
Like I said, our new CA was really good.
Like, the money has gone up.
- Yeah.
- And it's better than
what it used to be, but it's, like, nowhere near what we feel like
we deserve or where we want it to be.
- The steps the WNBA is making around pay
is very multidimensional.
So the owners and the league stepped up
in the last collective bargaining agreement
to triple the pay of the top players.
To give a lot of other offseason capabilities
in order to grow not only their on-court skills,
but their off-the-court skills
The average tenure of a WNBA player,
any professional athlete, is not that long.
And they need to, you know, be gaining skills
while they're still playing in order to see
what they're gonna do post their playing careers.
So, we've got internships.
We've opened up coaching opportunities,
not only in the WNBA but the NBA and the G League.
And, you know, there's some—
Kristi Toliver's a great example of that, you know, coaching
for Dallas this season, in the offseason.
We also have league marketing opportunities
and team marketing opportunities.
So, players and what we're doing over the course
of this collective bargaining cycle is giving players
a lot more opportunities to earn more money.
We introduced a new special competition during
the 2021 season.
This year will be the second, called the Commissioner's Cup,
where just the winner of that will get $30,000, each player.
So, more opportunities for players to make more money
in order to, you know, have our players really prioritize the WNBA
as their season and their job
- In the NBA, we talked about how social media
versus mainstream media—
- Mmhmm.
- How does it help or affect?
I feel like in the WNBA, you guys haven't had
a lot of mainstream media, but the social component
has been, has been pretty big.
- [Collier:] Mmhmm.
- Right? Whether it's activism,
whether it's the walk through the tunnels.
I love watching the women when—
- Yeah.
- They come in with they swag.
How do you think the social component of the world
has really helped the WNBA?
- It's helped us a lot, especially
because, like, one of the biggest problems is we're not on TV, ya know?
- Yeah. Mmhmm.
- When people watch us, they become fans.
Like, it's good basketball.
- Right.
- It's just, it's not accessible.
No one wants to go on Twitter or Facebook to, like, search
for a game.
- Right.
- We only get true fans doing that.
So, if there was, like, a Game 5 for the WNBA championship,
it wasn't gonna be on ESPN 1.  Like, that's crazy. So, we have to—
like, you guys supporting us is a huge part of it,
and it's awesome.
We also need the stuff—like, we have to be able to be on TV.
- I wanna ask a question.
- Yeah.
- Like, people always talk about, like, that they think
the W should have more teams.
I played in Sacramento, and, like, the Monarchs,
like, they got it all hung up, right?
And, like, they always talk about the legends of the Monarchs,
how good they were and things like that.
Like, but also—and I also see, like, the other side of the argument.
Like, if there is more teams and that's, like, more money
that's gotta go and then what happens to the salaries
and things like that.
So what's your take on that?
- We definitely need more teams.
Like, there's just too much talent to accommodate 144 people.
- Yeah.
- You have really good people not making rosters,
and the people who are on the rosters,
like, you're not getting playing time
because the talent is, like, so concentrated.
You have, like, rookies who aren't playing for years
because they're just behind good players.
- We're being very thoughtful about expansion.
I think it is on the horizon.
But we need to have our finances in a better place
and the economic model
so that new owners who start up a team in a new city
can thrive when they come in.
When you do only have 12 teams, 144 players,
there's a lot of players who get drafted in the second
and third round of our WNBA draft who may not make a team.
And Napheesa's right about thinking about
why there's so much talent out there that doesn't make
a WNBA team.
And we've gotta expand those opportunities,
which we're in the process of thinking through
- When the WNBA is in year 50
and they're celebrating their 50th year,
the NBA's celebrating its 100th year.
But what do you want the WNBA to be? What's the vision?
What's the goal in 25 years?
- Pheesa's seeing million-dollar contracts.
- I wanna see million-dollar contracts!
- Yeah, facts.
- There you go, million-dollar contracts.
- For sure.
- That's a fact. And I wanna get on Twitter and see people debating about, you know,
whoever's next up. Like, they better than Diana?
You know what I mean?
- Mmhmm.
- Are they better than Sue?
- [Laughing]
- You know what I'm saying?
- Who's gonna be the Michael Jordan,
where they're always competing?
- Yeah, exactly. That's what I wanna see.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
- So what I'd like the WNBA to look like in 25 years
at our 50th anniversary is it really needs to be thriving
as a really legitimized sports,
media and entertainment property.
Where the players are household names.
Where fans are consuming our content in whatever way
in 25 years consumers are consuming content.
Whether that's around AI,
augmented reality, VR, you know, all of the technologies
that are emerging today.
And that we're a global sport.
The future of the game is bright.
You see the popularity of the sport at the NCAA level.
You know, girls between eight and 18,
there's five to six million girls playing basketball
in America today.
So, I mean, it's a really positive sign
for the future of the sport.
And I think we will be able to go from survive to thrive
over the next 25 years.
- I feel like talent that's coming in, it's just,
it's just basketball
just keep getting better over and over.
- Yeah.
- Year after year.
- We keep talking about, like, the more accessible
the game is on TV—
and obviously they're doing things on social media—
but the more accessible the game is—
- Yeah.
- When people watch, they become fans.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, no doubt about that.
[Upbeat music]